ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman we have two absolutely huge
stories to start with today
and uh i wasn't sure which to start with
but let's just start with the first one
we have now learned that apple
has given the trump or gave at the time
the trump administration
information and documents on democratic
lawmakers and this is yet another
attempted or real abuse of subpoena
power
to obtain documents about the political
enemies of the trump administration
and we also of course have to consider
the role
uh which apple itself has played let's
take a look at an article from
thomson reuters which says apple
on friday said it has tightened some of
its rules
for responding to legal requests after
the u.s
justice department during donald trump's
presidency
subpoenaed it for information on
democratic lawmakers
apple said it recently instituted a
limit of 25
identifiers such as email addresses or
phone numbers
per legal request so so far what they're
saying is
if you're going to do this you'll have
to make multiple requests you can't give
us a list of 100
identifiers you'll have to give us four
four lists of 25.
the cupertino california-based company
said it received a subpoena from the
justice department
in february 2018 for information on 109
identifiers
made up of 73 phone numbers and 36 email
addresses but that it did not release
content
such as emails and pictures to
prosecutors the new york times on
thursday
reported and we will get to that report
that federal prosecutors subpoenaed
apple and other companies as part of an
investigation
searching for the sources behind media
news reports
about contacts between trump's
associates and russia
this is a key line what was the point of
this
what was it that the trump
administration the trump justice
department
was seeking to find out in requesting
this information
they were trying to uncover the sources
the journalistic sources for reporting
about trump administration contacts with
russia think back to when this was going
on
and there were reports about jeff
sessions said there were no contacts but
look at all these contacts that we found
uh donald trump said there were no
contacts uh you know the whole list of
these people
so the trump administration through the
justice department said hey you know
what
let's start figuring out let's get
information from people's iphones and
from the i cl from uh the icloud
whatever else was being used right
uh related to apple or possibly being
used let's see if we can figure out
who the sources are or were for what
these reports are claiming trump
publicly saying oh anonymous sources no
no no
they're just bogus but privately they
knew they weren't bogus
so much so that they were trying to
figure out exactly who they were
publicly saying when you read anonymous
source
doesn't exist there's no one there's no
real source
privately understanding there are
sources and trying to figure out
exactly who those people are the
investigation targeted at least two
democrats on the house of
representatives intelligence committee
aides and family members including one
minor the new york times reported apple
said it had no way to tell what the
nature of the investigation was
and released only basic account
subscriber information such as names
addresses email addresses phone numbers
as well as connection logs and ip
addresses apple said it did not provide
data showing
to whom or when messages of any kind
were sent the new york times
then reporting the justice department
subpoenaed apple
for information in february 2018 about
an account
that belonged to donald f mcgann ii
president donald j trump's white house
counsel at the time
this is another wrinkle to this story
this is another aspect
which we'll we're still trying to figure
out for the most part it seems what was
going on here
was an attempt to figure out who were
the sources for the news media
presumably on the democratic side about
these different
contacts that the trump campaign and
administration had with russians but at
the same time
the new york times report points out
that um
there was an attempt to get information
about donald trump's lawyer
as well and the new york times article
says it was not clear
what fbi agents were investigating
whether mr mcgann was their specific
focus
or whether he was swept up in a larger
net because he had communicated with
someone who was under scrutiny that's
another important aspect to understand
there are some on the right saying this
was not a partisan
thing being done by trump loyalists in
the justice department looking for
information only
on democrats as evidenced by the fact
that they were looking for information
about trump's own lawyer
what it may have been and if it is it's
absolutely crazy
that there was some other person being
scrutinized imagine that there was just
as a hypothetical some russian national
that was sort of at the center of this
the justice department may have been
saying we need information on anybody
who's been in touch with this person
and apple may have seen a connection
between mcgann and that individual
and so incidentally mcgann may have been
swept up on it we just don't know
at this point in time is the point now
meanwhile
as reported by cnn's manu raju
who tweeted over the weekend quote bar
sessions and now rosenstein
say they were unaware of the subpoenas
sent under their tenure
for democratic lawmakers records
these are three people with a track
record of dishonesty first of all so i
wouldn't trust them much
but what seems to be going on here is
that they are trying to get their
stories straight
for one word answers if they're ever
forced to testify how
nobody knew anything all of these
subpoenas were were filed
but nobody knew who who authorized them
who signed we just don't know
the administration was granted
years-long gag orders
against these subpoenas same as the
others these were gag
orders that were renewed multiple times
what judge okayed the renewal of the gag
order
on the fact that these subpoenas were
signed off on and granted
which judge or judges were involved do
we need to subpoena
the subpoenas to figure out who is
behind some of this stuff it is an
incredible story um it did not make
the headlines i might have guessed it
would have made or that
that i would have hoped it would make
but a major story
which we are going to continue following
another major story this weekend
of huge geopolitical and foreign policy
importance
is that long-time israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu of the likud
party is finally out as prime
minister replaced by the incoming prime
minister
naftali bennett in israel much of what
takes place is coalition based and so
what we have seen
here is that by a single vote margin
uh naftali bennett is in and benjamin
netanyahu is out
because of the coalition that bennett
was able to form the new york times
reports
the long and divisive reign of benjamin
netanyahu the dominant israeli
politician of the past generation
officially ended on sunday at least for
the time being as the country's
parliament gave its vote of confidence
to a precarious coalition government
stitched together
by widely disparate anti-netanyahu
forces
israelis israel's parliament the knesset
approved the new government by just a
single vote 60-59
with one abstention after his supporters
cheered the announcement of his election
naftali bennett then exchanged a brief
handshake with netanyahu
before walking to the rostrum at the
front of the parliamentary chamber
and taking the oath of office as prime
minister yair lupita centrist leader
is set to take mr bennett's place after
two years if their government can hold
together that long
they lead an eight-party alliance
ranging from left to right
from secular to religious that agrees on
little but a desire to oust netanyahu
the longest serving leader in the
country's history and to end
israel's lengthy political gridlock
in a speech made before the confidence
vote bennett hailed his unlikely
coalition
as an essential antidote to an
intractable stalemate
we stopped the train before the abyss
bennett said the time has come for
different leaders
from all parts of the people to stop to
stop
this madness now you will remember that
netanyahu as the article points out and
his right-wing allies from likud and
other far-right parties
did everything they could i i mean i
guess maybe there was something else
they could have done something
illegal i don't know they did almost
everything they could they applied
pressure
on other right-wing opposition lawmakers
they were trying to peel them away
from possibly being on the bennett side
but ultimately unable to
do it the question of course now is
what happens next it's important to
understand
that while uh naftali bennett is not
a likudnik uh the party likud of
benjamin netanyahu
there is the this political alliance
yamina
which is an alliance of right-wing
parties including
what was originally the new right uh and
and some other
parties and we will see ultimately how
it shakes out in practice now
it is still a right-wing coalition and
is still naftali bennett is still a
right-winger
um and it is a real question mark as to
as to what progress if any will be able
to be made
in terms of the israeli-palestinian
conflict now on the other side as i said
before
it is a requirement but it is necessary
but not sufficient
to remove benjamin netanyahu is there if
there is going to be any serious chance
at
peace talks that could be productive and
and permanent or semi-permanent as we
may call it
on the other side of that um hamas
we know simply cannot be
will not be they refuse to be there is
no way that hamas will be a party
to any kind of serious peace talks and
hamas seems potentially as ingrained as
ever
in gaza hamas near if you want to
understand sort of the outrageous
dynamics of what's going on there
hamas recently awarded al jazeera an
award which al jazeera
gladly accepted for their coverage of
the recent
conflict there and for anybody who has
um
legitimate criticism of the way that the
recent flare-up
with gaza was covered by certain
media outlets but does not have concerns
about the coverage of for example al
jazeera which was recently given an
award by hamas
you're sort of missing half of the
picture so i remain extremely
skeptical as to the progress that will
be made in the next
two years serious progress when it comes
to the israeli-palestinian conflict
but removing benjamin netanyahu as prime
minister was step
you know 0.1 it was a necessary step
it is not sufficient and we will now see
what happens next
it would be amazing if there were able
to be at least
some um uh initial
hypothetical uh guidelines set out for
some kind of serious uh path forward but
something that's important to understand
is
you know one of the risks of
casually following the internal politics
of other countries
is no matter who you follow like whether
you're following the new york times
and the times of israel or whether
you're following
al jazeera for your understanding of the
israeli-palestinian conflict
you sometimes miss the forest for the
trees and one of the things that is
really important to understand is that
within israel meaning to israelis
the israeli-palestinian conflict does
not actually rank particularly high
in terms of the concerns that the
israeli people have for what they want
a prime minister or the new prime
minister to focus on it's mostly
internal issues
it's internal issues related to
economics it's internal issues related
to
education and social services and
infrastructure
much like in the united states and it's
not different in that sense and this is
something that is really missed
when you look at israel and the
israeli-palestinian conflict
through any kind of western media
whether it's hard right or whether it's
hard left or whether it's centrist
our lens tends to be foreign policy of
israel and the israeli-palestinian
conflict
much like in the united states foreign
policy i mean listen in the middle of a
completely harebrained war with iraq
in 2004 uh george w bush
still was re-elected and the war in iraq
which
was like we went to war with the wrong
country over a lie about the connection
between saddam and 911
that's insane and even that only got the
war in iraq to
a reasonably important issue for
americans the primary issues were still
domestic economic et cetera it's no
different in israel
and i think that that's a really
important detail to understand
as anybody from outside of israel tries
to follow and understand what it is
that's going on there so netanyahu out
that's the good news
below that a whole bunch of other
details that
raise questions that have not yet been
answered
send me your thoughts about what you
expect if anything to change
with the removal of benjamin netanyahu
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
we will take a break what a packed show
today it's really a big one
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever
invited back ground news is one of the
first things i would use
to get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform
that lets you compare how outlets from
the left right and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how
sources with differing political biases
are covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spots stories that your side of the
political spectrum
may not have covered ground news can
help you build a well-crafted
argument for debating people you
disagree with or ground news
can help you discover something new
about your own perspective
challenging your own strongly held views
on political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the free ground news app today
by going to ground dot news slash
pacman remember that the david pakman
show is primarily
funded by individual members like you
you can
sign up today at joinpackman.com and get
instant access to so many great things
including the daily bonus show
you can hear uh my crazy
uh trip story sort of i guess on the
friday bonus show from last week i got a
ton of responses to it and people found
it entertaining and sort of horrifying
but
my my trip story is on last friday's
bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com coupon code is
available
better21 all right i have a story today
from my birth country of argentina and
it
is unfortunately just like the worst of
the worst of the stereotypes about
argentinians
one of the stereotypes about
argentinians
um is that uh they we
love to set ourselves apart from the
rest of latin america and say
the rest of latin america you know these
are hispanic people
but we're actually european now it's an
exaggeration
it's a stereotype it's extraordinarily
xenophobic and
and racist quite frankly and the current
argentinian president alberto fernandez
did exactly this during a meeting
with the spanish prime minister
alberto fernandez tried to sort of find
common ground and to connect with the
spanish prime minister
by highlighting hey we're european like
you guys and
in so doing he said you know the
mexicans are just indians
the brazilians came out of the jungle
we came on boats from europe we're
different and it is just the worst of
the worst
now many if you've been watching the
show for a while you know that i am not
a fernandez guy fernandez is in the line
of
christina kirschner and her late husband
i'm not i'm not a kirschner guy
now i'm also not a mockery guy i think
that basically in argentina
for decades now the choices have been
different types of corruption
different degrees of corruption none of
which serves the people
this is controversial among even within
my family where there are people who uh
are are big christina people who now is
the vice president they just
love christina and they're gonna write
to me because i'm saying this and say
i'm wrong about this i'm wrong about
that
it's one of the most disgusting regimes
that i've seen
but i'm not a mockery guy he did some
good municipal projects but it's not
like i'm cheering about
center-right sort of uh
trump-trump-style mockery so
in any case uh let's get into the video
i'm going to
um sort of translate i guess i would say
as we go there are some english
auto-generated subtitles but i will do
my best to kind of
let let you know what's being said check
this out
[Music]
[Music]
so here he's basically saying listen
argentina is part of latin america
we are pro-latin america we are latin
american but me in particular
i'm also a europeanist is the word that
not a pianist
a europeanist um because i want
we we consider ourselves part of europe
let's continue
i believe in europe
[Music]
so now he's quoting octavio pass but he
clearly
likes it and here's where it gets bad
que los
[Music]
mexicanos
[Music]
this this is if if if you were to do a
parody and say
what stereotype about argentinians could
we exaggerate
to make argentinians look as bad as
possible
this would be the script which would be
you know they say the mexicans
came from indians made natives and
native americans indian america
however whatever whatever phrase is
appropriate now to refer to the native
peoples
brazilians came out of the jungle as if
you can
imagine a more sort of primitive uh
imagery
um but you know we argentinians we came
from boats that came from europe
uh which of course is coded with racial
language and
it's it's just absolutely nuts let's
listen to just the end of it
[Music]
this is just the worst the worst the
worst of just
sucking up to the idea of of we
listen we develop we came from europe
and we developed the the country with
european
investment and it's just so racialized
and so
xenophobic and so disgusting and
in a sense it's not uh
um it's it's not even an attack
it's it's just this offhanded uh
signal as to how he views
brazilians and mexicans in comparison to
argentinians i'm so humiliated by this
that this is
so embarrassing because among friends
who understand the stereotypes about
argentina sometimes there are jokes made
about
stuff like this and you know if you go
to argentina and you see there's
essentially no what we would consider
black folks in argentina there's a
reason
why it's disgusting it's horrible the
history of it um
and uh you know there's a lot of
historical stuff here that
it would be great not to associate with
and then he just sort of like says what
for many of them is supposed to be the
quiet part
completely out loud i mean just just
absolutely humiliating and disgusting
this guy is horrible
it's it's horrible and by the way if you
want to if you want to see corruption on
a scale that would make
it would even make trump blush okay look
at what's been going on with vaccination
in argentina just just look it up and
see what you think
conspiracy theorist alex jones is now
claiming not only
that he paid five hundred thousand
dollars to organize the january 6th
insurrection in washington dc
but alex jones is claiming that he was
coordinating it
with officials from the trump white
house
now bear in mind alex jones lies all the
time
he may be lying here but he may not be
and even if a fraction of this is true
it's a whole new level of insanity
related to those riots let's check out
this clip
then the white house told me three days
before we're gonna have you lead the
march
the secret service before trump finishes
30 minutes before so
we'll lead you to a point take you out
of the front row and lead you
to the place where they want you to
start the march and trump will tell
people
go and i'm going to meet you at the
capitol if alex jones is to be believed
and we'll talk in a moment about whether
he is to be believed
he got his marching orders from the
trump white house
about the january 6 riots but understand
that
if one iota of this is true
the white house helped coordinate
the january 6 insurrection with
extremist conspiracy theorists
now we have some reasons to think
there's at least
something to this because there are
other reports connecting
some trump white house officials to the
planning of the insurrection so for
example media matters
previously surfaced some video of ali
alexander a so-called
stop the steel organizer bragging about
having been on the phone with people
from the white house
and seemed to be encouraging physical
violence that video has since been taken
down from youtube because it apparently
violated
some guidelines so there are data points
suggesting
this well may be true now given what
alex jones is saying
it's basically a full admission about
his involvement regardless of whether
his claims
about the trump white house involvement
are true is this even going to be
investigated
is alex jones being investigated by the
fbi for this i mean
given the number of confessions that are
floating around
what seems missing is someone's
conviction to take these confessions
seriously so
plenty of reason to think that this
should at least be
looked at as a serious thing and we can
see where the evidence takes us
now on the other hand yeah alex jones is
a serial liar
and when he's been put into legal hot
water in the past for things he said
his lawyers run in and then they say
he's merely an entertainer
he's playing a character on his program
the things he says on his program
aren't meant to be taken literally or
seriously he's sort of like a performer
and if that defense sounds familiar it
is the same defense that fox news's
lawyers used when tucker carlson got
into legal trouble
saying you know tucker engages in
hyperbole
it's not news reporting what he says
should not be taken literally it's a
stunningly common defense
of so many people that millions of
americans
are actually getting what they believe
to be news from that
see what comes out of their mouths as
facts or at least ostensibly
facts this is definitely a defense you
will not hear me use okay i can i can
promise to you today
what i say on this show is not
hyperbolic or performative in the sense
that it's not what i really believe
i might use hyperbolic language
sometimes it may occasionally be
inaccurate sometimes i get a fact wrong
and i will make every effort to correct
it
my opinion may change over time but i
don't pretend
to be me i am not playing a character on
this program this is not a defense you
will ever hear from me
now it would be great for alex jones to
provide some records and what i mean by
that is
if he was really coordinating things
with the white house
unless the belief is that these were all
in-person meetings
did he have phone calls with people from
the white house then show us the phone
records
are there text messages are there emails
there should be
some trail that would help to
show us if that alex jones is telling
the truth if he is
and of course we could really use a more
credible witness than alex jones but if
he has the goods
this would be a good time uh to present
them to us what do you think
you think alex jones is telling the
truth you think he's lying
you think he's simply exaggerating let
us know we'll have more coverage of this
on the david pakman show instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
and uh follow me while you're there at
david.pacman quick break
right back after this don't forget that
the best way to support the david pakman
show is by becoming a member which gives
you access to the daily bonus show the
regular show with no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
so against my better judgment i decided
over this past weekend to
do live coverage of the mike lindell my
pillow
frank speech rally in wisconsin and
i always love being with you guys love
sharing events with the live audience
but this one was really really tough to
watch it was
truly an historic event organized by
mike lindell
a big trump supporter founder and ceo of
the mypillow
brand it was a four hour event i was
only able to get through about two and a
half hours before
i just had to bail uh the lineup at this
event
included mike lindell himself diamond
and silk charlie kirk brannon howes
chris cox dinesh d'souza danielle
d'souza sheriff clark and of course
donald trump himself
joining the event via video conference
now 99
of what happened at this event was
merely the disgusting nonsense you would
expect
the event had a scheduled flyover it
failed i guess the planes like didn't
show up it was
really weird but it was really capped
off
by donald trump delivering a deranged
and bizarre speech during which his eyes
appeared almost
completely swollen shut we've seen this
with trump a couple of times before
he was also slurring and seemed to be
engaged in a real battle against his own
tongue
which was determined apparently to
prevent him from being able to enunciate
anything clearly
and this rally while disgusting and
depraved
it really confirmed our suspicions they
seem
fully intent on riding this horse into
the 2022 election
that's the trump horse and they will see
how far it gets them
trump launching right into his entire i
actually won the election thing
the talking points have been the same
for six months and trump
just labored struggling to speak take a
look
we went from 63 million votes and we won
to 75 million people and they say we
lost but we didn't lose
75 million votes they say that we lost
now i was told by john mclaughlin who's
considered
just about the best pollster i would say
the best pulsar there's a few of them
out there
towery there are a few of them out there
that are great sir you got 63 million
if you can go up to 65 you can't lose
the election
well you know what happened we went up
to 75 and they say we lost the election
if you win miami if you win florida if
you take out
and win and we won by a lot florida and
ohio and then you add iowa
nobody's ever won those states and lost
but we won those states in virtual
landslides
and they have us losing and there are so
many we held every state house
we held congress you know it's all so
labored and of course
it's the same lies week after week
as you can hear the crowd is not exactly
riveted
by what donald trump is saying here is
donald trump delivering a defense of i
guess rudy giuliani
but it's hard to tell if he really means
it but just not looking good not
sounding good i want to thank people
like rudy giuliani
who is out there fighting and they're
after him and they want to take him down
they want to take us all down there's
never been a time like this
there's never been it's weaponized it's
weaponized and the republicans were very
nice
our people were very very nice and very
very respectful
and i said this would happen but rudy is
a great patriot he was the greatest
mayor in the history of new york
and a great great patriot and what he's
done and what mike has done and what so
many other people have done
these are incredible heroes and they're
going to go down
as heroes someday and i think it's some
day in the not too distant future
so i look forward to being with you
hopefully they go down
uh but not as heroes hopefully they just
go down for their crimes and misdeeds
then here is trump really just
fighting that tongue to enunciate
coherently saying china should pay the
world for the virus
but kind of weird yeah take a look and
the china virus
they have to pay reparations we've been
hurt
so badly in terms of death human life
and in terms of monetarily to a level
that they have to pay us and
frankly if they paid us 10 trillion
dollars that wouldn't cover it
but they really have to pay the world
because this has started
in the world the entire world has been
not only disrupted
um and just the slurring uh the
the eyes uh almost completely shut
during this next segment and then the
video froze which in a sense was like
the best moment of the rant when the
video froze
having a hard time with the contractors
i know contractors
better than anyone they're very
brilliant they may not read or write in
some cases but you know what
they're smarter than the rest smarter
so i just want to thank everybody the
video freezing
seemed to get the crowd more interested
than anything trump had said
up until that point at another moment
donald trump falsely claimed to have
stopped the russian oil pipeline like it
just didn't happen it's just factually
untrue
i stopped the russia pipeline probably
the biggest pipeline in the world going
into germany and other countries in
europe
it was stopped never happened just it
didn't happen it's not true
a few other really strange moments here
are diamond and silk apparently
explaining
something about the so-called audit in
arizona
of the absentee ballots see if you can
understand this
question for you okay i notice how the
democrats
is trying to interfere in the
certification
of the audit wonder why i remember them
saying that it's an
insurrection when you try to block
the certification so my question is
if they're trying to interfere in the
artist in arizona for example
does that make them an insurrection
because they try to stop
the verification of the certification
of jim crow joe
good way of looking at that
i don't know guys that's pretty strong
i'm i'm pretty convinced i don't know of
what but i'm pretty convinced by that
another favorite moment was when mike
lindell claimed
that uh i guess a friend of his had
he was banned from google maps um
really weird a friend of mine about a
month ago
i was on his radio show and they put up
he sent it out the podcast part
to all his subs he emailed it out 30
thousand emails
google took away his gmails and his
google maps
i want you to think about that they took
away as google maps
i feel like i need an interpreter to
even understand
what it is they are claiming like i i'm
having trouble even adjudicating the
claims that are being made by these
people
because i don't even know what the
claims are and then lastly maybe the
funniest moment
this is a crowd heading for the exits
while mike lindell is speaking
apparently the crowd had had enough
we're in the greatest revival for jesus
in the history of the world all right
but i want to tell you all so i'm going
to tell you what i want to do is i want
to bring it back because how did i end
up here how did we end up here today
especially when i you know here's the
next crack addict from minnesota
so i'm going to tell you a little i'll
bring you back in time
you know so if you're listening today
and not watching the crowd was just
heading out while mike lindell was
speaking
um this one of my favorite segments from
the trump era
is a segment where trump went to india
and this big
stadium full of people started heading
towards the exits as donald trump was
speaking and mispronouncing all sorts of
indian names
this was the equivalent this was the
equivalent during the mike lindell rally
so another completely humiliating event
but signaling a few things to us
number one the trump crowd doesn't seem
to be that worried about sunburn and the
reason i say that is
this was a four hour event which opened
two hours early
and people just sitting in the blazing
hot sun the entire time i hope they
brought sunscreen but they don't seem
super concerned about sun exposure
that's one thing we learned and number
two uh they really seem to be on this uh
they're they're not changing horses
midstream
i think would be the the metaphor that
we would apply to this
they seem committed to at least seeing
what trumpianism is going to bring them
through 2022 if it fails then maybe
they'll go a different direction but
yet another complete and total
embarrassment not to be outdone
by marjorie taylor green although she's
trying let's talk about
that next q anon friendly
radical trumpian republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
said she doesn't believe in evolution
during a bonkers off the wall interview
with steve bannon on his so-called war
room program now i want to be really
clear here
if you want to simply see this as it's
just another
nutty thing marjorie taylor green said
and leave it at that
you can do that but understand that the
world sees what i am about to play for
you
and the world is shocked the civilized
world anyway how does the united states
still have people in the house and
senate forget about people who deny
climate change
that ship has sailed but we still have
people in the house and senate
who deny evolution and
i want to get into a little bit later
the terminology of
don't believe in evolution we're gonna
get to that because
that's a problem too the context was
apparently covid19
and the lab leak theory and it caused
marjorie taylor green
to casually drop in that she doesn't
believe
in evolution okay let's listen you hang
on you don't buy that you don't buy the
argument that say hey the gain of
function is all because we've got to
take these viruses and we've got to
power them up
to look for vaccines and to look for
other solutions
in case somehow they they come up with
this you don't buy it you don't buy the
logic of that is that what you're saying
no i don't buy it because i don't
believe in evolution
i don't believe in in that type of
so-called science i don't believe in
evolution i believe in god
and there's these viruses were not
making people sick
until they created them and made them
and to weaponize these viruses to be
able to attach to
to our cells and make us sick this has
caused
so many people to die all over the world
this is a bio weapon
all right so the terminology
she doesn't believe in evolution
so the virus couldn't have evolved but
she believes in god
but then says the virus was created by
them meaning
china but how could china create
anything if everything is god's creation
that's crazy and coherent i don't even
want to focus about that
focus on that today that's not that's
crazy but i don't want to focus on that
this is an outrageous ramp and it's an
ignorant screed
but understand that this is a member of
the united states congress voted in by
her constituents in the state of georgia
when i first saw this story
i scrolled by and i thought it said oh
marjorie taylor green says she doesn't
believe in education
that's not actually the headline but it
might as well be so let's talk about
belief in evolution i hate it when
people say this
maybe it's you don't accept evolution
it might more accurately be you don't
understand
evolution but don't believe in evolution
it seems
it makes it seem as though it's an issue
of faith
imagine if someone didn't believe in
gravity we'd say well what difference
does it make
you have no choice but to accept it and
to exist in a physical world
in which gravity is a reality you might
not understand it
but to not believe in gravity sounds
as idiotic as you imagine it to be
and so when people say i don't believe
in evolution
it should really be thought of in the
exact same way it should sound
just as strange to us she doesn't
understand it
she apparently wants to keep other
people from understanding it
but the main point here is if i said
i don't believe the sun is the source of
heat on the surface of the earth
i might not accept it i might not
understand it
but the reason i can go outside and it's
a temperature that is suitable for human
life
is that it is the reality it doesn't
matter whether i understand it or accept
it or believe in it
it's really dumb to say i don't believe
the sun heats up the earth
and it's really dumb to say i don't
believe in evolution
people who say it should be seen the
same way as people who say i don't
believe in gravity
i don't believe the sun heats the earth
these views
should be ostracized and they should be
called out
but the most important part is this
should disqualify you from
from being an elected official if you
don't accept or understand or
believe in to use their term something
this uncontroversial how can you be
trusted to do anything about any issue
ever
now one funny thing if anything were to
make me question evolution
it would sort of be marjory taylor green
what i mean by that is
life has evolved for millions and
millions of years
we come out of the ocean and down from
the trees and we develop medicine and
science and netflix
and technology and air travel and yet
somehow marjorie taylor green
still exists i'm kidding i'm kidding but
i'm also
sort of not if you understand what i'm
saying horrifying
that this is what we have we have 435
members of congress
and she doesn't understand or accept
evolution to use her word she doesn't
believe in it
it's a global humiliation my friends and
it must be changed
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show
you know i really was feeling like we
had kind of seen it all recently
related to strange comparisons to the
holocaust or references to jews or
thinly veiled anti-semitism
you know we heard about marjorie taylor
green's so-called jewish space lasers
marjorie taylor green saying wearing a
mask on the house floor is like the
holocaust or
mandatory vaccinations which don't exist
are like the holocaust but a woman
claiming to be a registered nurse she
may be a registered nurse i just mean
i don't know that to be true she says
she's a registered nurse it's scary if a
registered nurse would believe what i'm
about to play for you
but a woman claiming to be a registered
nurse appeared on cnn yesterday
and claimed specifically that covet
vaccination
and the medical trial process for
developing new drugs
is like nazi medical experiments of the
world war ii era she says it's not
exactly like it but it's sort of like it
you simply have to see this to believe
it
this is a completely disgusting woman
let's get right into it we're not going
to say this
is nearly as big as the holocaust was
but it's not nearly as big as the
holocaust was
but and then here we go at the beginning
the way they did make
people have trials and injections
medications
procedures against their will this is
pretty much what they're doing right now
what who's having procedures against
their will
who's taking medications against their
will who's been
forced to do anything do you remember
what was
we'll get to nazi medical experiments
they're
having forcing people to take a shot
when they don't
want to nobody is being forced to take a
shot
nobody is being forced to take a shot if
you want to travel to some countries
you can decide i will do the things that
are required to go to that country
if you want to sit in the vaccinated
section that will be full rather than
only one third full at certain stadiums
then you can choose to go and get
yourself vaccinated nobody is being
forced
to take a shot they're not giving the
proper informed consent
like nobody is being told the risk
factors before getting this injection
that is completely untrue when i went
and i got my very very powerful modern
vaccine
i was screened with a like an eight
question
initial screening i was then given like
a two-page
document about it then the person giving
me the shot
asked me a bunch of questions then i was
so told to stay in observation for 15
minutes and for my second shot all of
the same stuff happened
all of it is nothing this woman is
saying is true it's hard
it's actually hard to keep up with all
the things she's saying that aren't true
okay i just want to be clear though i
mean you do realize
that there is no comparison here to the
holocaust right i mean the
nazi doctors held medical experiments
on people and some died some i mean it
was painful it was awful
right how could you eat yeah but
somebody's arm hurt from the vaccine
then compare it to that
i i didn't compare to the holocaust but
i did compare to the beginnings of it
which is the nuremberg trials
oh that is it's not it's like it was
like the beginning of the holocaust
the nuremberg trials the nuremberg
trials were
at the end uh they took place between
i would guess you know 45 and 46
and um yeah maybe she means nuremberg
laws but the nuremberg
she doesn't know anything guys is the
point now to
to really put a fine point on how
disgusting this is and these people
they you know get getting vaccinated
against something that has killed
millions of people
is nothing like the experiments
conducted
by german doctors um during the
world war ii the first of all the
conditions were inhumane
there was complete lack of consent the
research standards were questionable at
best
and uh look at the things that were
actually done during world war ii
um prisoners were frozen
to try to find treatments for
hypothermia
exposed to extreme cold prisoners were
used to test
methods of making seawater drinkable
people were drinking salt water
uh forced to drink salt water prisoners
were exposed
to phosgene and mustard gases
in order to test antidotes
a whole bunch of different sterilization
type experiments were done especially
at auschwitz and ravensbrook
a scientist tested ways of doing mass
sterilization
on jews nobody was held hostage
and forced to get vaccinated here people
who wanted to participate
in the vaccine trials chose to
participate in the vaccine trials
they were told the risks jews didn't
have that opportunity
the culture of conspiracism but also
historical ignorance she doesn't even
know enough about the holocaust
to realize what she's saying is how
to realize the degree to which what
she's saying is absurd
and she almost seems proud of it
defiantly making these claims well
it's sort of like some aspects of the
holocaust
like the nuremberg trials at the
beginning of the holocaust
what what and i hope
that whoever her employer is if she is a
registered nurse
sees this video and then decides like
employers are able to do
thanks to republicans saying employers
should be able to do whatever they want
hopefully her employer will then decide
this
is someone that should be working for us
or this is someone that we should be
parting ways with
over the weekend apparently what fox
news host
judge jeanine pirro believed we needed
more of
was another xenophobic anti-immigrant
rant
on her program and so she really did a
number
on her saturday night episode here is
janine
saying she doesn't give a damn about why
undocumented immigrants are coming here
that their reasoning for coming here is
merely a distraction
i'm after the pandemic and i don't give
a damn what the reason is for their
coming here and neither should you
it's nothing but a ruse to prevent you
from answering
the harder question now of course this
completely does away with our ability to
say you know
somebody who was under 18 and was
brought here by their parents and has
committed no crime
is very different than someone who came
over
as an adult and maybe did commit some
kind of violent crime
that eliminates the fact that we are
reasonable people
who can look at circumstances and say
actually it really does matter what the
circumstances of people getting here
uh were then the big surprise of the
show
is judge jeanine trop trots out
donald trump's daughter-in-law lara
trump laura lara trump
who says hey you know what you people at
the border
because you know biden's not doing a
damn thing about it
you need to get yourself some guns and
take matters
into your own hands what here is the
idea
disgraceful to see and i don't know what
you tell the people that live at the
southern border
i guess they better arm up and get guns
and be ready
and maybe they're going to have to start
taking matters into their own hands
it should never happen these people
should never make this dangerous journey
here
that's an idea right i mean if the nra
did product placement it would be
let's get prominent right wingers
loved by the fox news audience to go on
to fox shows
and talk about how people should buy
guns like this this is
the nra couldn't buy advertising this
good for their
clients who are the gun manufacturers we
have a country
plagued by mass shooting after mass
shooting after mass shooting
last week i reported to you we had 10
mass shootings the previous weekend
most of them didn't even make major news
stories once again this past weekend i
don't even have data for yesterday yet
but when i looked on friday we had
another four mass shootings in the
united states a total of four killed and
17 injured at the four
friday shootings then we go to saturday
in the united states
we had another four mass shootings four
killed
31 injured really the only one of any of
these that made
significant news was the one in austin
texas where 14 people were injured as of
the last
time i checked fortunately nobody was
killed
every day three to five mass shootings
in the united states
endless smaller shootings where maybe
only one or two people
are injured or killed and lara trump
shows up and says hey
go and get guns and be ready to use them
and take things into your own hands when
it comes to
migrants at the border who they may be
undocumented they may not be as if it
really even makes a difference when it
comes to
suggesting people become some kind of
vigilante force this is the exact
statement
that made in a different context made by
somebody else
might be investigated as a possible
crime
in many situations a good rule of thumb
to live by
here's a here's a little like life
advice for people who who are seeking it
and apparently many people are um if you
have a situation you're analyzing
whatever it might be
and you start to think you know what
might be a good solution here
introduce more guns into the situation
stop
stop and really evaluate whether that
makes sense because in 99.99
of situations where there's a problem
introducing more guns
is not the solution almost without fail
introducing more guns is likely to give
you
a worse outcome than a better one so
this is very dangerous
sickening rhetoric it is exhausting to
deal with and it's kind of like a game
of a whack-a-mole
trump's out of office but now lara trump
is regularly appearing on tv and saying
the absolute worst reactionary instincts
in every situation no matter the issue i
got an email from someone saying you
know david
what she did is really a crime if you
look at 18 us code
subsection 373 solicitation to commit a
crime of violence
you're not going to get her on that
because if if pressed there's enough
ambiguity where she would say no no no i
just meant people should have guns in
case
you know undocumented immigrants
trespass on your property or they try to
physically attack you or your children
or whatever the case
you're not going to get her on that you
i understand but you're not going to get
her on that
it's almost as if like they planned
their crimes openly
and then they end up not being held
accountable and mostly that has worked
for trump and this is not merely
theoretical
remember back in uh when i believe this
was in 2019
uh we had that el paso shooting
where the suspect said he was targeting
mexicans this rhetoric has a real
impact it's not trivial it's not merely
hypothetical
it's not merely an academic question
this is rhetoric that gets people
to commit violent acts in real life it's
horrible it's disgusting
and and sadly there's every indication
it's going to continue
we have a voicemail number you can call
the voicemail number
really whenever you want and many people
call it times of day that are
times i tend to be sleeping but that's
okay because you can call any time of
day
here is a caller it is the eggman the
eggman has really been on an
anti-mask tear lately and i guess he's
blaming me
for his daughter wearing a mask listen
to this
hi dave so i'm headed out on saturday
afternoon with my
15 year old daughter and she says oh
darn it dad i forgot my mask
and i tell her kid you don't need one
you're double vaccinated
you're good to go and she says well you
know i i know i don't need one but i
just don't want people to look at me
like i'm like ah
my kid now dave has the attitude be
that attitude because you and so many
people keep perpetuating to
wear masks even if you're vaccinated
idea dave we got to stop this
you know that it's virtue signaling i i
admit that it's virtue signaling i know
why is eggman blaming me
know it let's move past this i want to
see somebody without a map
and not know if they're an anti-vaxxer
or vaccinated
i don't want to judge them by that
anymore you don't need to wear them
anymore that's what
cdc says so um i don't know let's not
worry about hurting other people's
feelings
shalom brother my kid's listening to
this so now i'm going to get judged yeah
well listen the eggman should be judged
and
um i don't know what is going on from
the standpoint of parenting over there
but
listen i've said i don't it's almost
like groundhog's day here where i keep
saying the same thing
we've been following the cdc guidelines
all along and so why would we now all of
a sudden stop following
cdc guidelines what i have admitted is
merely for issues of
i'm making a social decision where
if i stick my head into a grocery store
as i did yesterday
and everybody's still wearing a mask i
just put the mask on
partially because i get recognized at
the grocery store all the time
and i don't think it would be a great
thing for me professionally
if i'm photographed or seen as being the
only unvaccinated people in the grocery
store so
it it's total virtue signaling i agree
with that um
but i think what the egg man's daughter
has learned and this
this is actually a great lesson is that
we can understand the science
we can understand the cdc guidelines we
can feel safe not not wearing a mask if
we are vaccinated but
for social reasons we might say here's
something i'm going to do just to make
it easier on me
some people don't care if everybody's
staring at them because they're the one
person not wearing the mask
and that's one personality type but the
eggman's daughter
seems to have a sense of self where she
says you know
i'd rather feel safe either way but just
throw the mask on even though i don't
need it just so
i don't attract attention to myself that
i may not want
that's a perfectly reasonable
calculation to make in society
uh as i said before i never thought i
needed a mask to just be out by myself
on my bike on the bike path
but at the point at which everybody was
doing it i just did it
and it just made things easier for me
and there's value in that as well all
right eggman
uh little egg everybody i hope you're
doing well shalom
we have a great bonus show for you today
jeffrey toobin
after being caught exposing himself
during a zoo meeting is back and he's
apparently been promoted on cnn it's
wild what's going on
north carolina has decided to end that
really stupid coca-cola ban
you probably forgot about it but
remember when there was a boycott of
coke in north carolina because they
what did they even i don't even remember
what the controversy was they uh
crap what what did coke do they
supported voting rights i guess it was
or
i don't even remember we'll talk about
it and apple iphones will soon be able
to hold your id
privacy experts are on edge we will talk
about
those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a
member
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman